hey crazies say you've got a bowling
ball in a boat as you look deep into the
water beneath the darkness beckons in
your soul you feel an overwhelming urge
to drop the ball does the water level go
up go down or stay the same we'll get
into it after the intro feel free to
pause and think if you need to
[Music]
why would we have a bowling ball in a
boat who doesn't have a bowling ball in
their boat anyway I used to frequently
give this question to my intro physics
students and their most common response
was that the water level would go up
they'd say objects in water displace
that water so putting a bowling ball
into water would displace it like
anything else raising the water level
but as it turns out the water level
can't go up if nothing enters the system
the bowling ball is already in the
system so that only leaves us with two
options either the water level stays the
same or it goes down
stays the same doesn't it actually it
depends on whether the bowling ball
sinks or floats bowling balls can float
yep any bowling ball under about 12
pounds or 5.5 kilograms will float on
water all the heavier ones sink let's
take a look at the floaters first
poop jokes
[Laughter]
here we have an analog for each item in
our system first we'll fill up our lake
with water it's not a lake without water
then our system begins with the boat in
the water and the ball in the boat we
should Mark the water level before we
change anything this is our new Baseline
then we take the ball out carefully
place it in the water and wait for
everything to settle checking the water
level again shows that it hasn't changed
which makes sense if you think about it
the ball is floating regardless
afterward it's floating on its own but
beforehand it's using the boat to float
the water is still supporting the weight
either way and you can see that when you
work out the math too the before picture
looks something like this everything is
in what we call mechanical equilibrium
meaning the forces all balance each
other in this case gravity pulls
downward on the boat and the ball that's
their weight there's also upward support
from the water which we call buoyancy or
buoyant force that buoyancy comes from
the weight of the water itself when you
put something like a boat into water it
takes up space that used to be occupied
by water that water got pushed out of
the way and ultimately upward above the
original water line but water also has
weight and it's trying to fall toward
the Earth just like everything else in
the process that water pushes back
resulting in an upward force on the boat
the two find in equilibrium though in
this new water level becomes our new
Baseline now let's take a look at the f
after picture when the ball is lifted
out of the boat the water level goes
down but then it goes back up when the
ball is placed in the Water by the same
exact amount in this case yes we have
two objects independently in equilibrium
but the physics works out the same each
gets a buoyancy and each gets a weight
adding everything together we recover
the same result we got before even
though the displace volume is a
different shape it's still the same
amount of volume
so what happens if you drop a 16 pound
bowling ball instead the ball will sink
and the water level goes down we'll swap
for a seal ball so we guarantee it sinks
just like before we place the boat into
the water and place the ball into the
boat
I'm gonna need a bigger boat
it's not big enough
nope
[Music]
tipping over
here we go hey yo there we go just a
little bit of tape
I hate experimentation alright after
some troubleshooting we're using a
bigger boat and some tape to hold the
ball in the middle so it doesn't tip
over and bingo bango it works hey yo now
we mark off our new Baseline and then
move the ball into the water as you can
see here the water level went down what
makes this different from before the
ball went from floating to sinking the
boat may be able to support a 16-pound
bowling ball but the water can't and
that matters oh yeah it's everything the
before picture looks just like it did
with the floating ball gravity pulls
downward on the boat and the ball
buoyancy pushes up the only difference
is that this ball is heavier so the boat
Falls deeper into the water the after
picture is a bit trickier to figure out
a time-honored physics tradition is to
take a question like this to its extreme
just to see what happens let's take that
bowling ball and compress its mass into
a smaller space say it's compressed so
much that it's the size of a dust
particle it's the same mass as the
bowling ball just with a tiny volume
when the particle is inside the boat its
weight uses the volume of the boat to
displace water but outside the boat the
particle barely displaces anything at
all it would be the same for a sinking
bowling ball just less dramatic if less
water is displaced then the water level
goes down
though you should be careful with
Solutions like this first for the
comparison to work both the bowling ball
and the extreme object have to sink if
you were to take the bowling ball and
expand it instead you'd quickly make an
object that would float rather than sink
breaking the comparison another problem
is that if you compress a bowling ball
too much the electrons will smash into
the protons you'll get neutronium that's
the stuff neutron stars are made of if
you put something like that into a lake
it'll explode taking the lake and you
with it and there goes your experiment
we're better off working through it
without any tricks like we said the
before picture looks like it did for the
floating ball but this time we'll go the
extra mile and solve for the displaced
volume of water you can see it depends
on the mass of the boat the mass of the
ball and the density of the water this
is what we're going to compare to our
after picture once the ball Falls all
the way to the bottom of the lake here's
what the forces look like just like in
the floating case each gets a weight and
each gets a buoyancy however the ball
also has an upward push from the bottom
of the lake because remember the water
couldn't entirely support it the water
gave it a valiant effort with its
buoyancy but it just wasn't enough this
upward push makes up the difference and
brings the ball back into equilibrium
after you work through some algebra
you'll get the new displaced volume of
water this big term out front is just
the displaced volume for when the ball
was inside the boat but now we have a
second term and it's subtracted that
means the displaced volume after is less
than the displaced volume before the
water level has gone down same
conclusion no tricks just basic
principles what about when the ball was
falling through the water though you get
a very similar result
this upward push from the lake floor
would just be mass times acceleration
instead it's basically the same equation
but here's the super main ultimate Point
some bowling balls float on water and
some of them sink any bowling ball 12
pounds or less will float in which case
the water level stays the same because
the water could support the ball either
way any bowling ball 13 pounds or more
will sink in which case the water level
goes down because it takes more water to
support the ball than it does to just
let it sink if you want to use some kind
of trick to solve puzzles like this
that's fine but you have to be careful
if you're unsure just do it the more
rigorous way and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
the doctor was wondering why there are
multiple bright spots in our image of a
black hole great question accretion
discs aren't uniform these three blobs
are denser parts of the disc where it's
hotter the only reason this one looks
brighter than the other two is because
it's moving toward us anyway thanks for
watching
the lake demands sacrifice